on parle de théâtre dans le 7 8 avec les
40 ans d'une compagnie emblématique du
territoire yvelinois c'est la troupe du
crâne et on en parle avec Christophe
Loret bonsoir vous êtes le président de
cette troupe du crâne un bon
anniversaire à vous alors l'anniversaire
officiel c'était même l'année dernière
puisque la troupe a été créée en 1992 on
va revenir sur cette histoire mais
l'anniversaire va se poursuivre avec
cette année 2023 des notamment des
représentations dont on va parler qui
ont lieu des ce week-end à Maurepas déjà
40 ans pour une troupe de théâtre ça
représente quoi pour vous bien beaucoup
de rencontres beaucoup de comédiens et
beaucoup de spectacles surtout dans des
configurations très différentes et
vraiment de très belles aventures il y a
35 membres dans cette troupe du crâne 14
comédiens l'objectif c'est de monter une
ou plusieurs pièces de faire partager
ses créations tout au long de d'une
saison oui exactement il y a la volonté
de faire vivre les spectacles les
anciens de de créer toujours aussi de
nouvelles productions et puis d'avoir un
d'élèves donc on a des ateliers
justement pour les niveaux collégiens
lycéens donc il y a aussi cette idée de
la transmission qui est très importante
pour la créatrice parce que il y a un
personnage central dans dans une
personne centrale dans cette histoire on
le disait ça a été créé en 1982 la
fondatrice c'est Monique fondillon qui
est toujours aujourd'hui la méthode en
scène de cette compagnie qui a joué un
rôle important tout au long de
l'histoire c'est le personnage qui est
fédérateur c'est elle qui a créé donc
cette association en 82 elle a donc eu
au par le passé une une carrière sur
Paris une formation au Conservatoire et
puis quand elle a emménagé dans les
Yvelines elle a eu le souhait de
justement de créer sa propre compagnie
et ça s'est fait dans des conditions
presque un pittoresque dans une grange
avec quelques petits moyens et puis au
fil des décennies on a eu des lieux des
subventions le soutien de la ville de
Coignières de Maurepas et puis et puis
après la résidence puisqu'on joue au
théâtre Alphonse Daudet où c'est notre
voilà notre théâtre de résidence et là
qu'on travaille deux trois fois par
semaine et puis après bien l'histoire a
pris beaucoup d'ampleur votre métier
vous vous êtes scénographe vous exercez
comme profession on doit notamment à
différentes scènes de compte celle du
château de Breteuil pour ne citerkel la
troupe du crâne vous y êtes entré à 13
ans qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous êtes
tourné vers le théâtre à l'époque et
qu'est-ce que ça vous a apporté alors ça
m'a apporté énormément de choses donc
oui je suis rentré à 13 ans j'en ai 35
donc ça fait 22 ans
c'est vrai que la troupe m'a apporté
vraiment la vision de ce qu'est l'art de
la scène et de sa multiplicité aussi
c'est-à-dire il y a il y a plein de
métiers il y a plein de le costume
m'intéresse la technique m'intéresse le
son m'intéresse aussi énormément et
cette approche globale a été
passionnante mais je dirais que c'est le
travail avec les autres on est une
troupe c'est un groupe le travail avec
le metteur en scène des enseignement
qu'on retire et moi ça a été un moteur
pour moi c'est une rencontre essentielle
dans ma vie celle de Monique fond
d'idiot et c'est aussi une amie très
chère aujourd'hui et puis et puis
effectivement ce sont les auteurs que
l'on met en scène notre matière première
ce sont les mots et aborder vraiment
dans la chair rentrer dans la chaire des
mots c'est
vraiment quelque chose de passionnant
alors en 40 ans en quelques chiffres il
y a une quarantaine de pièces qui ont
été jouées alors dans le répertoire il y
a du Shakespeare Molière du fedo une
dizaine de pièces aussi écrite et mise
en scène par par Monique fondu Dion
différentes dates alors celles que je
m'étais notée il y en a beaucoup en mai
2018 c'est aussi la troupe qui obtient
sa première licence de spectacle et qui
peut honorer des engagements
professionnels c'est vrai que de peu à
peu on est passé d'une aventure amateur
à une aventure quasiment professionnelle
exactement grâce à cette licence on a pu
honorer des engagements professionnels
on a eu l'opportunité de jouer au
château de Fontainebleau pendant 50
représentations
spectacle de la Belle et la Bête gros
partenariat un énorme partenariat et du
coup bien ça nous a ça a été des
tremplins et puis les engagements sont
arrivés aussi donc il fallait avoir la
structure administrative pour donc on a
fait évoluer les choses alors pour fêter
cet anniversaire je disais donc 1982
2022 mais ça se poursuivre en 2023 il y
a notamment des photos qui sont exposées
à l'espace Albert Camus de Maurepas et
je le disais deux représentations au
programme ce week-end à l'occasion du
Festival Plein feu c'est toujours à
l'espace Albert Camus déjà samedi 4
février à 20h30 c'est un fedo un fil à
la pâte qui est donc par votre troupe la
troupe du crâne est mise en scène de
signes de Monique fondidon
finalement fedo ça fait partie un peu de
vos classiques ça a été souvent souvent
on a joué pas mal de pièces du
vaudeville effectivement c'est très
difficile à jouer de votre ville parce
que ça demande une énergie d'enfer c'est
un rythme effréné ça demande une grande
concentration une grande précision mais
surtout beaucoup de folie et
dans le fil à la pâte on ne Déroche pas
à la règle c'est 2h30 c'est un grand
spectacle avec un beaucoup de costumes
des décors une équipe une équipe de fou
furieux et c'est vraiment un spectacle
où le rire est à chaque situation donc
on en a beaucoup besoin je crois que
c'est une belle manière d'honorer le les
40 ans de la troupe dans la joie et la
bonne humeur et le lendemain à 16h je
précise juste qu'il y aura une pièce de
Molière c'est le bourgeois gentilhomme
il y a toutes les informations qui qui
vont s'afficher notamment aussi pour
pour
l'habilletterie j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter à la troupe 40 ans supplée 40
ans de plus peut-être
continuons cette belle aventure et
vivons les choses intensément parce que
rien ne remplacera le spectacle vivant
je pense que les personnes qui sont à
mes côtés le confirmeront aussi c'est un
un lien entre le public et les artistes
sur scène qui est unique c'est une
expérience à vivre à tous les niveaux et
je crois qu'il faut l'encourager et
vivre le théâtre et vive la scène tout
simplement merci merci beaucoup
Christophe Laurent d'être passé bientôt
pour en parler bon anniversaire une
nouvelle fois à la troupe du crâne merci
c'est 40 ans et bien sûr des temps forts
à venir à toutes les informations via
les liens les liens qui s'affichent en
bas de l'écran merci beaucoup merci